everything that you are aware of is
constantly changing but
that which is aware of it remains
consistently present
throughout all changing experience in
fact that
aware presence that we refer to when we
say i
is the only element of experience that
never changes
i actually want to start at the end to
perhaps give us an idea of
where we're heading how do you define
enlightenment
i would suggest that enlightenment is
a rather exotic term that has
acquired all sorts of um
uh exotic and superfluous
meanings for people but that it really
refers to something
very simple and well within
everybody's grasp and it is
simply this the recognition
of the nature of one's essential being
or self so it's innately linked to some
sort of truth
we could say it is the truth about what
we essentially
are now when i say what we essentially
are
i mean that aspect of ourselves that
never disappears cannot be taken away
from us is is inherent or
integral to us so for instance
uh the current conversation that you and
i are having
is not inherent in us it started a few
minutes ago
and it will come to an end it's not part
of our essential being
indeed no thought that we have ever had
is essential to us all thoughts appear
they exist briefly and they vanish
likewise our feelings however
uh however intimate
or deep a feeling may be it is still
something that is added to us it lasts a
while
and then it vanishes the same is true of
any relationship
or activity so if one were to imagine
removing everything from ourselves
that is not essential to us what would
remain
would be what i referred to as our
essential
irreducible self or being the
recognition
of its nature is what is referred to
in the religious and spiritual
traditions as enlightenment or
awakening so it feels a lot like that
is casting off rather than learning more
it feels absolutely it feels like we
need to get rid as opposed to acquire
well it's actually not even necessary to
get rid of anything
it it it is simply necessary to see
clearly
that all those elements of our
experience
namely thoughts feelings activities
relationships sensations and perceptions
are not essential to us we don't
actually have to get rid of them
or change them or discipline them we
just have to
realize they're not essential to us the
the
analogy that i sometimes use to
illustrate this is the analogy of the
the screen and the image now no
image no movie is essential to the
screen
if you close down all your programs your
emails your iphotos your notes your
youtube clips your word documents you
close down all the programs that you
have running
through the day what what remain what
what can't you close down
you even remove your screen saver which
is not
essential it seems to be there always
but actually it's not essential
to the screen what remains just the
transparent empty screen
so yes it's a similar process it's a
process of
um removing from oneself rather than
adding to oneself but it's removing
presumptions i think what you're
highlighting there is the fact that
these things don't necessarily need
removing because they were almost never
there in the first place
yes you're absolutely right what we're
actually removing
is the belief that any of these
elements of experience define or limit
us
given that approach what does it mean
to say that you rupert
at the same rupert that was rupert 20
years
ago or that i chris and the same chris
that was chris 20 years ago or will be
in 20 years
okay well can we start by not going as
far back as
20 years can we start with let's start
with two minutes
two minutes to go and we'll go to 20
years
but let's let's start a little closer to
home
so let me rephrase your question what
what does it mean to suggest that chris
is the same chris
now that he was two minutes ago
well the thoughts that
you chris are having now are not the
same
as the thoughts you were having two
minutes ago
the feelings if indeed any feelings are
present
are not exactly the same your bodily
sensations the
the sensation of the air on your skin
the sensation of your hand on your mug
the sensation of your legs
on your chair they're not exactly the
same as they were
two minutes ago the sound of my voice
the content of our conversation the
sight of your room
none of these are exactly the same as
they were
two minutes ago they've all changed
evolved
appeared disappeared but there is one
element of your experience
that is present now knowing or
being aware of the content of your
current experience
that was present two minutes ago
knowing or being aware of whatever it
was
that you were experiencing then and that
is what you refer to when you say
i so now you say
i am listening to your voice i
am experiencing thoughts i am feeling my
legs
on the chair the sounds the thoughts the
sensations on the chair
these all come and go but the eye that
knows them
is the same i that
knew or was aware of your experience two
minutes ago
two days ago two years ago 20 years ago
or when you were a two-year-old boy
in other words when you were a
two-year-old boy you
knew or were aware of
your experience
the feeling of being in your mother's
arm that the sight the the sound of your
parents the sight of your room or the
garden or you were having experiences
and
you were aware of your experience as a
two-year-old boy
as a ten-year-old boy as a 20 year old
young man etc
all everything that you are aware of
is constantly changing but that which is
aware of it
remains consistently present throughout
all changing experience in fact that
aware presence that we refer to when we
say
i is the only element of experience
that never changes it is our essential
irreducible self the one element of our
experience that cannot be
removed or separated from us
why are you pirouetting around the word
awareness
is there a reason to avoid using
awareness
as a word no
um i wasn't aware that i was oh no i'm
[Music]
you see chris i'm i'm not sure
who's listening to this conversation i
don't want to presume
anything of course if i were having a
private conversation with with you
i would use the word awareness freely
because i know
i i don't know you well but from what i
know of you i know that you understand
that we both share our understanding
of the word awareness now
some people the the word awareness that
they've
they may have heard of it once or twice
but they've never thought of it it
doesn't relate to something in their
experience
however if i were to say just to
let me give you an example if i were to
walk now out onto the onto the high
street
and say to someone do you know what
awareness is
that they would look they would look
puzzle them what
what do you mean if i was
to say to the same person are you aware
of your experience
they would just say yes
i understand so that's the i don't even
remember now exactly how i phrased my
answer to your question
but it was i you see having these
conversations i want to do my best
not to present any linguistic
uh barriers or to provoke
objections or resistance and just trying
to make this easy
accessible experiential and everybody
knows what i mean
when i ask the question are you aware of
your thoughts
are you do you perceive the sight of
your room
do you know your feelings everybody
knows exactly what i mean by
knowing or being aware of their
experience
but now coming back to your question
about the word awareness
we could say that that which is aware of
our experience
the common name for it the name that we
give to it is
i i know my thoughts i am aware of my
feelings
i i perceive the world
but we could also call it awareness or
consciousness
that which is aware of our experiences
consciousness or awareness
now that down just one thing to add to
that the downside of
saying referring to it as a awareness
awareness being a noun
tends to suggest that what we are
referring to
that which is aware of our experience is
some kind of an object
and that is the that is the pitfall or
the downside of using the word awareness
everything that we are aware of is some
kind of an
object some kind of a thing but
awareness itself
that which knows or is aware of our
experience is not any kind of an object
so we have to understand that when we
use the word
awareness we don't i don't mean to imply
that it is
some kind of a subtle thing
how does what we've gone through so far
relate to non-dualism
at large or if it doesn't at all then
can you give us an introduction
to non-dualism yes no it does relate to
it
very directly the non-dual understanding
or the perennial philosophy as it's
sometimes referred to as the
is the understanding that really
underlies
all the world's great uh religious
spiritual and philosophic philosophical
traditions and if we were to distill
the non-dual understanding however it
may be expressed in these
different traditions if we were to
distill the essence of that
understanding we could describe it in
two
simple phrases firstly
the nature of our being or self
is happiness itself and
we share our being with everyone and
everything
these are the two core understandings
that that really are the essence of the
non-dual
tradition in whatever cultural context
that understanding has been expressed
the expression of course is very
different in each case depending on the
time and the place in which it was
expressed but the
understanding that was being expressed
was always the same
is always the same and it is namely that
happiness is the nature of ourself for
being
and that we share our being with
everyone and everything
why would happiness be the substrate
that we grow out of why not another
emotion
it's just that that's the way it is
it's just if if you were to
um can we try a little a little a
little experiment to try to illustrate
absolutely
because then we will um
make this very experiential and not just
philosophical
if i were to ask you chris to describe
as best you can that which is aware
of your experience so i'm not asking you
to describe your experience your
thoughts your feelings your sensations
your perceptions
i would ask you to describe that which
is aware of your experience
in other words your essential self or
being what
what would you say
thinking of words like insight
center it's the center of yourself yes
it's the essence of yourself
try to describe it's can you try to find
words
that would describe its qualities if we
could
open open completely open like a
like an open space of a room simply
experiencing whatever appears without
prejudice
impartial choiceless yes completely open
without resistance yes can you say more
like an aperture on a camera yes that
allows you to focus in
and focus out yes you can focus the
camera on a single object
or the camera can remain unfocused and
just take in the entire
visual field the presence of awareness
we can focus on the content of our
conversation
or we can relax our focus and simply be
be aware
of the entire spectrum of our experience
without
preference or choice perfect yes what
else
has a texture to it sometimes it can
feel high fidelity
sometimes it can feel like an old vcr
camera
okay so i suppose i would say it's
changing
as well there is a there is a change to
it in its
nature in the way that it feels in the
way that i experience it at least
you see now i think you're you're
beginning to subtly describe
what you are aware of
so take a step back what is it that is
aware
of these changes
i keep coming back to aperture open
which is the openness it's just this
aware openness so let me ask you a few
more
specific questions about it is there any
agitation
in it you now your thoughts may be
agitated
you're you're you may be in pain in your
body in which case your sense
your sensations will be uncomfortable
there may be
a crisis on the street outside your
apartment or
but so my question is not about
the agitation in what you are aware of
thoughts
feelings is is there any agitation in
that which is aware of your experience
i would say no in the same way as
a camera simply observes what it's
looking at
perfect the camera never gets never gets
agitated it may be
it may be watching uh showing something
that is agitating on the lens yeah
precisely
exactly but the lens itself is never had
energy
what is the common name from a human
perspective
for the absence of agitation peace
peace and that that peace
is the nature of awareness it is nothing
to do with the content of your
experience
your thoughts may be agitated your
feelings you may be upset
there may be a commotion on the street
but that which knows or is aware of
all of these like the camera doesn't
share
their agitated qualities it is at peace
and it's not a piece that depends upon
the content of experience it is a piece
that is prior to
and independent of the content of
experience
so let me ask you one more question
is there any lack in the presence of
awareness
there may be feelings of lag or the
thought
i need something i am lonely but
that which is aware of your thoughts and
feelings
is there any lack in it i don't think so
it feels like a like a conduit
for whatever is going on outside exactly
exactly and what is the the common name
for the absence of lack
in human experience peace
yes yet you're right a little more
um give me one more word is it happiness
it's happiness
peace and happiness they're really the
same
so the reason i'm saying this is because
you asked me why is happiness the nature
of ourselves and i said it it's not for
any reason it just happens to be
the way it is so what i've tried to
demonstrate to you or rather what i've
tried to
lead you to in your own experience is to
recognize that
that happiness is peace and happiness
are the very nature
of yourself that you don't need to be
made happy
you don't need to manipulate your
experience
in order to find peace and happiness
peace and happiness are
the very nature of yourself they are
they are prior to
and independent of the content of
experience
i'm not sure if it's my disposition
around the word happiness
and obviously anything linguistic comes
with its own baggage
right because my happiness and what it
means to me isn't quite the same it's a
very
we need neurolink we need elon musk to
hurry up and allow us to just do
brain-to-brain communication so we can
dispense with these pesky words
yes i feel much more comfortable
and it makes more sense to me to hear
the word peace than it does to hear the
word happiness
peace to me feels like what we've talked
about a stripping away of lacks
a stripping away of fixating or
suppressing happiness to me feels
more like there's something in motion
yes
um chris i think you're you're
absolutely right
and i tend to agree with you
um the reason i
use the word happiness is because if we
were
to do a survey of all
7.8 billion people in the world and ask
them
what is it you want above all else most
people would start by giving a list of
um a relationship a family a better
health
a nice household these kind of things
but then if we were to ask them but
but why do you want these things
almost everyone would answer because i
think they will make me happy
in other words happiness is the thing
that people want
experience that people want above all
else
most people that would would
conceptualize
that for which they long above all else
as happiness but it could equally be
peace
joy love that these are all synonyms
really so that's why i include
the word peace and and happiness you're
right
that that
one of the downsides of using the word
happiness is because of the
common association that most people have
with it
namely that happiness is a fluctuating
emotion
that alternates with suffering
so um and that is not intended i would
suggest that happiness is not not really
an emotion
in the sense that um jealousy hurt
and upset anger anxiety fear our
emotions
i would suggest that happiness is is the
ever-present
background of all emotions it's like the
blue sky behind the clouds
it's always there it doesn't mean say
it's always visible
because it's sometimes covered by clouds
but but the blue sky and the grey clouds
don't alternate with each other
the blue sky is always there it's
sometimes
seen and it is sometimes obscured i
would suggest that peace or happiness
are the nature of our self
and simply by virtue of the presence
that our self is always present
so peace and happiness are always
present but this doesn't mean that it's
always
felt why not because it is obscured by
the
by the gray clouds of thoughts and
feelings
it's an analogy that i've been using for
a long time that you are the sky and
everything else is just the weather
exactly that the thoughts and feelings
would be the weather that come and go
but
what does this what is the sky's
attitude
towards the weather indifference no
attitude at all
complete indifferent the sky doesn't
feel that it needs
something from the weather the sky never
says oh
it's a thank goodness it's a sunny day i
can't wait for it to stop raining on
it no because the sky feels whole and
complete
irrespective of what is what the weather
is doing well
awareness is like that it is we could
call it the blue sky of awareness or the
empty space of awareness yes
so let's use the word happiness
considering it is the uh
lexical commonality that is most useful
what do you think are the most common
impediments that people have to
attaining happiness
and to kind of just append onto the end
of that
given that happiness in how people
define it
might not actually be what they're after
they may be after something
closer to peace but what are the things
in your experience that get in the way
of that
whether someone conceives
what they long for above all else as as
peace or happiness
i would suggest that the one thing that
gets in the way of their recognition of
it as the very nature of themselves
is the belief that it can be acquired
via objective experience
in other words in order to be happy i
need to change
something about the content of my
current experience
my health needs to improve my financial
situation needs to
improve my relationship needs to improve
my finances need something needs to be
changed i need something
something objective an object a
substance an
activity a state of mind a relationship
i need something and when i get that
whatever it is
then i will be happy that this
this belief which we have um
inherited from our culture and which is
almost continually reinforced by our
culture
is the main impediment to the
recognition that happiness is that
the nature of our being and is available
to all people
at all times i've been reading a
jed mckenna book recently i was
introduced to him by a friend
and i've been very very impressed if
anyone that's listening wants to
read it uh it's enlightenment the
damnedest thing
i think is the first one in his in his
series and he talks about
releasing the tiller on that so the
tiller being the handle that
steers the boat he talks about how a lot
of people grip
very very tightly onto this tiller in a
desperate attempt to try and steer
themselves
and it's really it's a beautiful analogy
that's made me think a lot is you're
talking now about the fact that
we presume that by doing better steering
or faster steering or more agile
steering
that's what's going to get us towards
the end goal
peace of mind happiness that's true but
but that belief
that we might steer the boat a bit more
carefully a bit more efficiently a bit
but
that belief is it's not the fundamental
belief
there is a belief that underlies that
namely that
when i acquire a certain experience in
the future
then i will be happy that's the
fundamental mistake
and holding the tiller is the route
to achieving the thing yes it is the
route and
i may think i do it more if i do it more
efficiently
if i if i hold it tighter if i so that
that is a secondary
belief that i'll get to this future
happiness quicker if i just improve
my techniques of getting there gripping
the tillers
more strongly but but the fundamental
belief
the primary belief is that happiness
peace and happiness are dependent on the
content
of experience that belief is a
recipe for disappointment and suffering
does this mean that there is no such
objective better state or worse
state for somebody to be in surely
suffering an illness and
not at all not at all i don't mean to
imply
that it isn't legitimate to
um take care of oneself and one's family
if one
has one financially to educate one's
children
to to take care of one's self uh
to to to live in a a place that one
likes to have friends that no no i don't
mean to imply that that is not
legitimate all i need to imply
is that one should not do any of these
things for the sake of finding happiness
but still perfectly okay to have a
desire you had a desire to interview me
on this on your podcast it wasn't to
have
the desire wasn't motivated you you
weren't feeling miserable
you didn't think oh i must have a
conversation with rupert i feel better
about no
it was you you were already feeling that
the joy of this
understanding and your desire arose out
of that joy the desire to spread it and
to share it and
so so i'm glad you asked that question
because this
understanding doesn't in any way imply
that it is not legitimate
to take care of oneself and to think
about one's future one's education to
look after one's children once
once health one's finances etc
the motivation for a lot of that comes
from the felt lack
though right we see a state
which we believe would make life for
perhaps ourselves or those around us
better that it would improve their life
or our life in some pla
in some way well again it depends what
does the desire
uh to um
does the desire that arises does it
arise
on behalf of a sense of lack or for
instance does it arise on behalf of the
um
the safety and the well-being of the
body
that would be perfectly legitimate
you're sick
you don't just say oh i'm sick my
happiness is not dependent on
the state of my body i'm not going to do
anything about it no it's true your
happiness is not dependent on the state
of your body but it's still appropriate
to take care of your body to to to feed
it or your
your child if you have a child or
someone who's in your care
so and what i'm suggesting doesn't imply
in any way that one doesn't
one doesn't have a desire that one isn't
motivated
to do certain things it's just that the
motivation no longer comes
from a sense of lack objective
experience is no longer seen
as the means to find or secure happiness
i guess this means that we need to be
very careful about what desires we have
and where they come from exactly exactly
but the only all that's important is to
be aware
of desires that come from a sense of
lack
there are many other reasons that a
desire may arise
uh a design may arise as i just said on
the on behalf of the safety
or the well-being of the body uh your
design may arise from a feeling of
happiness
from a feeling of love you may you may
be feeling
at peace
totally fulfilled you may call a friend
and ask them around for dinner
not because you think your friend is
going to make you happy because you're
already feeling
fulfilled you just want to share that
with your friend go go or go for a walk
or
your desire to to have this conversation
didn't arise
out of a sense of like it arose on
behalf of your love of truth
that's another reason motive for
desires to arise to to explore
or express or to share or to celebrate
truth or reality
that's another legitimate um motive
for a desire an impulse to do something
that doesn't come from the sense of lack
there's only one type of desire
that that diminishes and as a result of
this understanding namely the desire
that comes from a feeling of lack and
the belief that
the object the substance the state the
relationship that is acquired
will provide happiness for us that's the
only
type of desire whereas the only motive
of our desire that
falls away in the face of this
understanding
i've got the words gap and fear
in my mind as you're talking about that
um gap comes from a concept by ben hardy
where he
discusses the difference between gap and
gain so he says a lot of the time
people when they're driven to do
something they look at a thing that they
want
they net off the difference they
subtract the difference and find that
there is a gap
between them and it as opposed to the
inverse which would be
this is something that would be great
for me to do i am compelled i'm pushed
forward as opposed to pulled along
and that's the gain and then fear i
think i
i keep on talking about it i'm so
adamant that
many of the people that are driven to do
great things in the world
are doing them out of a fear of
insufficiency that
if i build the next business
create the next product get the next
million subscribers whatever it might be
this will fill the hole in me i am not
worthy
of love or compassion or care or
companionship
as i am and with this that fear
can be dispelled and and and of course
as
as we as we well know um getting the
next
uh million or acquiring whatever it was
we were
we we were striving towards does not
give us the happiness we long for that
the feeling of emptiness
is possibly briefly
eclipsed but but by the the acquisition
of the million dollars the the whatever
it is
but sooner or later and usually sooner
rather than later
the the old feeling of lack the void the
empty feeling comes back
up and now next time round you need a
stronger dose of whatever it was another
million won't suffice
it's got to be 10 million it's
or or if it's a substance or an object
or relate you tend to need
more of it to to give you that same
fleeting sense of happiness and and that
that fleeting happiness
it it lasts for less and less time
before the old
sense of lack comes up and sooner or
later
one gets to a stage where one feels i've
explored everything
nothing i found in my life has given me
the lasting peace and happiness
for which i long i've tried everything
and that is um either a moment of
despair
for people because there's nowhere else
to turn
and this often precipitates despair or
depression
but in others it can precipitate either
spontaneously or the suggestion of a
friend or reading a book or watching a
youtube clip
it can trigger this intuition
that they have been looking for
happiness in the wrong place
and there can be this spon as a result
there can be a
a spontaneous turning around by turning
around i mean
a turning around of the mind away from
the content of experience and we begin
to
investigate what who
who i really am prior to
my thoughts feelings sensations or
perceptions and this is the
this is the um the beginning
of the path that leads to the
recognition of our true nature and its
innate peace and happiness
do we have an ex experiment that we
might be able to do to help
identify what we are at center or
identify our awareness in that way
yes we could um
we could imagine gradually
removing from ourselves
everything that is temporary or
objective in our experience
so just imagine removing your thoughts
and then remove your feelings because
all no feeling is permanent they all
come and go
remove your memories
remove your aspirations your hopes
remove your relationships
however close they may be no
relationship is permanent
it cannot be essentially what we are so
imagine
removing your relationship remove your
activities whatever activities you may
be engaged in no activity is
permanent remove the sensations
of your body all sensations come and go
so it is i sometimes liken it to
a process of undressing we are not
taking off our clothes
we are taking off the layers of
experience that are
not essential to us but
and just as when we get undressed at
night
but we reach a stage where we can't take
anything else off
it's just our naked body in this
experiment
it's exactly the same we get to a stage
where we can't take off any more layers
of experience
we have in our imagination removed from
ourselves
everything that can be removed what
remains
just naked aware being
and in that one there is no agitation
and no lag that is
the happiness that everybody looks for
nearly always through the acquisition of
some kind of objective experience
how does this relate to the non-dual
part of the terminology does this mean
that we are in the world
and of the world okay
when i first offered a definition of
non-duality i suggested it had
two parts to the understanding the first
happiness is the nature of our being
and that is that that's where we've
our conversation has been centered
um up till now the second aspect
which is more specifically which if
from which the term non-duality comes
more specifically
is the understanding that we share our
being
with everyone and everything in other
words what we essentially are
is the same as what everyone
and everything essentially is in other
words there aren't
two separate independent realities or
entities in existence mind and matter
self and other god and world
there is a single
indivisible infinite
reality from which everyone and
everything derives
its apparently independent existence
so the first aspect of the non-dual
understanding the nature of our being is
happiness relates to our
internal experience it's just about our
own inner life
the second aspect of the
non-understanding relates to our
relationship
with others and the world and it is from
this second aspect of the term
non-duality comes
that there is a single reality it
appears
as if there are ten thousand things but
that
a that is an appearance
of a single reality just as
when you look at uh you watch a football
match
on the screen you
you seem to be seeing 10 000 people in
the crowd
but really you're looking at one screen
the 10 000 people
are an appearance of the single
screen and this in other words the
screen is the reality
of the apparent
10 000 people so i would suggest
that uh beneath or behind the appearance
of multiplicity and diversity
there is a single unified reality or
whole it's not really behind or beneath
when i say it's behind or beneath that
is a a concession
to to the belief that appearance of
things
are independent of this
underlying reality so it's not really
true to say that the screen lies behind
the movie
but as a concession to one who believes
that the landscape in the movie is real
we might at least to begin with say no
understand
that the screen lies behind it
so to begin with we might make a
distinction and talk about
appearances and their reality
the movie and the screen but of course
the appearances and their reality
the movie and the screen are not really
two separate things
but the former is simply
the appearance of the latter all there
is is really the latter all there is is
the screen
it just sometimes appears as a movie all
there is
is reality infinite consciousness or
awareness
it sometimes appears to us as a
multiplicity and diversity
of objects and selves
the biggest distinction i think that
most people make
is that they feel like an actor who is
an agent
that works within the world as opposed
to
an extension of the world right we feel
like there is a
self behind the eyes in the head
somewhere
tootling about doing our daily business
yes exactly exactly um
chris takes the analogy of a dream when
you have a dream at night
and this is a nice illustration of this
second aspect of the non-dual
understanding the fact that we share
our being with everyone and everything
when you have a dream at night
you you forget that you are dreaming you
overlook your mind
overlooks the fact that it is dreaming
and it imagines a
dreamed world within itself the
dreamer's mind imagined
a dreamed world but it doesn't view the
dreamed world
directly in order to see the dreamed
world
the dreamers mind localizes itself as a
dreamed character
the dreamer's mind seems to become a
character in its own dream
and it's only from the perspective of
the dreamed
character that the dreamers mind is able
to perceive
what is in fact its own activity
as an outside world now from the point
of view of the dreamed character
exactly as you say the dream characters
feels i am a
separate independently existing agent or
self
acting of my own volition with my own
energy in this world relating to
objects and others and
that that i feel more or less separate
from now of course when we wake up
we realize that sense of separation of
otherness
of being an independently existing
person in the dreamed world is a
complete illusion
the whole thing was the activity
of our own mind which is
itself a unified field albeit a limited
one
so in this analogy i would suggest that
the dreamers mind
is a microcosm of the universal mind or
infinite consciousness which is
so to speak dreaming or imagining the
universe
within itself in other words the
universe is the
is the the mental activity of the one
mind the universal consciousness
but it cannot view that
universe directly because the infinite
cannot perceive the finite directly in
order to view
its own activity it must localize itself
within its own imagination as an
apparently
separate subject of experience from
whose perspective it views its own
activity
as an apparently outside world so it's a
very close analogy
to what takes place on the level of an
individual
dream the dream insights really
interesting
i don't tend to remember many of them
but it's so weird that you don't have
the god's eye view
if this is you did you ever play
civilization sydney as civilization the
game
yeah so you sort of this omnipotent big
you're right you don't you never have
the god's eye view you can lucid dream
in which you know you're dreaming but
even then when you're lucid dreaming you
still
perceive the dreamed world from the
localized perspective
of the dream character it's just that
you realize that the whole thing is
taking place within your own mind
i had a dream a couple of weeks ago
where i was kidnapped
by scousers from liverpool and they
forced me to do their marketing for them
that was that was how i spent most of an
evening apparently
just relaxing doing some marketing for
some people from liverpool so
why is it given the fact that this seems
quite compelling
why is it that natively
we have such a different experience of
reality to this perspective
because we experience reality from the
localized
and limited perspective of each of our
minds
and the the our our finite minds
impose their own limitations
on everything that they perceive so the
finite mind is like a pair of glasses
or let's upgrade the analogy the finite
mind
a human finite mind which consists of
the activities of
thinking and perceiving is like a
virtual reality headset
we put on the virtual reality headset
and
reality the the outside reality
appears in accordance with
the limitations of the vr headset
through which we perceive it
if it is calibrated to work in terms of
thinking and perceiving then the
universe that we perceive
will appear in accordance with those
limitations
but if the vr headset had other
faculties
the world with the reality we perceive
as the world
would be would appear in accordance with
those faculties
it's like um did you ever as a as a
child go into a 3d imax
cinema yes yeah and you you know what
you remember when you
i haven't been for years now so they're
probably a lot more modern
but you used to go and you get given a
big clunky pair of
goggles and you look on the screen and
it's just a regular screen and all
you're seeing
on the screen is just a fuzzy pattern
it's just a
no a completely abstract fuzzy it looks
as if
it's like an old-fashioned tv set that's
malfunctioning
then you put on your glasses and
suddenly
you're immersed in an ocean in which
there are fishes
swimming all around you so the the
the vr goggles that you have put on
renders what is actually
a two-dimensional screen as a
three-dimensional environment
and you don't feel that you're viewing
the two-dimensional screen from the
outside
one feels that one is participating in
the three-dimensional
reality the ocean or whatever it is from
the inside
so that the the structure of the vr
goggles that we have put on renders the
two-dimensional screen
in a way that is consistent with the
configuration
of the the goggles well i would suggest
that
a human mind is like a vr
headset that functions in terms of
perceiving and thinking
and the reality we perceive appears
in accordance with its limitations
so what i am not suggesting is that all
there is
to reality is the contents of our own
finite mind that would be solipsism
i'm not suggesting that i'm suggesting
that there is
a reality that is outside each of our
finite minds
but that it appears in accordance with
the limitations
of the finite mind through which it is
perceived
in other words the world owes its
reality
to infinite consciousness but its
appearance
to the finite mind now what's the
relationship between the finite mind and
infinite consciousness
find that mind is simply a localization
or rather an apparent localization of
infinite consciousness just like the
dreamed character
is an apparent localization of the
dreamer's mind
given the fact that you've worked at
this for
40 years maybe more than 40 years now
50 i've this i've
i first had this intuition when i was
seven or eight years old
cool a while so it's it's really i've
always had this intuition it took me a
long time i had to forget this intuition
i had to go out into the world i had to
suffer i had to trace my way back
to my own experience i had to so it's it
took
a long time for me to to to make my
early childhood intuition
my own actual experience
so given the fact that you've worked at
it for half a century
yeah can you try and describe
the distinctions in your experience
now what's it like to be somebody
who has worked at this and worked at
this and worked at this for
five decades can you talk to the delta
between
rupert then and rupert now in terms of
the texture of your mind
the way that you experience things it's
it's very simple chris and very ordinary
it's nothing
nothing extraordinary it's
and
the really that the two differences from
the rupert then and
the rupert now are two differences that
that i could
um speak of in two in terms of these two
aspects of the non-steal understanding
the first
is that i have understood clearly
that the peace and happiness that i love
cannot be derived from objective
experience
so i have ceased looking for happiness
in objective experience
it is clear to me that happiness
peace that which i love above all else
is the very nature of myself
so if that innate peace and happiness
are eclipsed or veiled
at any stage in my life the impulse
to find it again
through objective experience no longer
rises i just go straight back to my
being
that's the one one thing and the second
thing
and this is something that the deepens
it's not a fixed state or a final state
it's something that deepens
um in time my the sense that i
sh that i share my being
with everyone and everything increases
the the the common
the common way we express
this felt sense of our shared being in
relation to people and animals is
called love and in relation to objects
and nature it's called beauty
that's what the experiences of love and
beauty are the collapse of the felt
sense of separation
so there is this progressive dissolving
of any sense of separation between
myself
not just in people than my people
animals objects
so that in other words another way of
saying that would be that
the appearance of multiplicity and
diversity
becomes as it were increasingly
transparent
it is progressively losing its power
to veil its reality and as a result
our shared reality the reality we share
with everyone and everything
shines through appearances more and more
strongly
does this lead you open to feeling other
people suffering more than you would
have done previously
it does chris yes the extent to which we
are empty of the suffering
that attends the belief in separation
so we become more and more sensitive to
other people's
suffering for if we if we're consumed
with our own suffering another way of
saying this if we're consumed with our
own personal suffering
there's not much room to be empathetic
towards somebody else's and we only feel
somebody else is suffering if it's
expressed in in their very bold strong
terms we wouldn't be sensitive to the to
the
slightest the smaller degrees of
suffering that
many people have but to the extent that
we are empty of our own
suffering so we are sympathetic or
empathetic
to the suffering of others yes do you
find that challenging
it's challenging to
it would be challenging to myself as a
separate entity
but to the space of awareness no it's
not challenging
so it depends where i locate myself
at the moment i experience if i feel
i'm i'm a separate self then another if
i'm lost in the sense of separation then
another
person's suffering can be challenging if
i'm not only understanding but by
feeling myself to be this aware
openness the sky of awareness then no
it's not challenging the weather is
never challenging for the sky
let's say that there's someone who's
listening who your
avatar earlier on the person who has
tried and looked in different places for
happiness
filling it with relationships or
experiences or emotions or
objective metrics of success let's say
that there's someone to whom that
resonates with
right it is completely attuned to to
their
experience of life right now what would
you say to them
i would say when you feel
suffering when you feel any any moment
or period of suffering in your life
instead of doing what you normally do
reaching for
whatever it is in your particular case
that the the fridge the bottle the phone
the the
etc etc pause sit down
close your eyes instead of going
outwards
towards the object the substance the
activity the relationship
go in the other direction ask yourself
the question
but who is the one
who is suffering not what am i feeling
loneliness sorrow shame guilt fear but
who is the one it is
it is i who i'm feeling upset it is
i who i'm lonely it is i who i'm afraid
of
who is this i what am i really so you
begin to trace your experience inwards
towards yourself rather than tracing
your suffering
following your suffering outwards
towards the object the substance the
activity
and in this way you trace your way back
through the layers of experience
until you come to this inherently
peaceful presence of awareness and then
you rest there that is the resolution
of your suffering
rupert spiral ladies and gentlemen
rupert if people want to
find out some more about your work or
delve deeper into non-dualism where
would you send them
the first place would be youtube i have
um
a ridiculous number of youtube clips on
youtube
three four hundred i think so so there
go to youtube first have a look at my
channel explore there
if if you're interested go to my website
rupertsborough.com
there's a lot more um there's a whole
archive
of all the meetings that i've conducted
over the last 10 or 12 years
there are books and i do webinars every
week
meditation weekends where we can have
conversations and so
that would be the place to go if you're
if you're still interested after you
sampled some clips on youtube where
would you suggest they begin with your
writing what book
i would suggest two books depending on
your
inclination if you're very
philosophically minded you want to delve
into
the nature of reality i would
recommend the nature of consciousness
but if you want a
simple experiential approach
i would recommend being aware of being
aware
or in a couple of weeks time a new book
coming out called
being myself so these these two books
being aware of being aware and
being myself are short simple
experiential they're just the essential
non-dual understanding if you want
something more involved
and philosophical try the nature of
consciousness
i love it rupert thank you so much
thank you very much chris thank you for
asking it's been a pleasure speaking
with you i wish you the very best
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy indeed
peace